>> Sam: IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE H
ESTABLISHED HIMSELF IN THE
LEAGUE AND EVERYBODY GLOVE SAME.
STROME ALONG THE BOARDS FOR LAF
AGAIN.
LOOKING TO MAKE A SAVES.
TIME TO TAKE A DEEPER LOOK WITH
SAYING THEY DID
OF COURSE THEY WERENE OF THE
YOUNG PLAYERS JUST SCORED HIS
NET.
WHAT A PLAY BY
FOR IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT ROLES, SAM.
I
ZACH A DRIVE!
WIDE, THE BOUNCING REBOUND WAS
DIFFERENT TEAM GOT
TWO MINUTES EACH FORHE
BOARDS FOR BOLDY.
BOLDY'S BEEN PRETTY GOOD.
ZUCCARELLO.
DRIVE BY TALBOT AND KREIDER IS.
THROUGH THE LEGS AND THE 2-2.
THOSE
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS MINNESOTAH
HE KNEW EXACTLY WHAT TO YOUNG
OUTSIDE YOUR BUDDY
FIVE OR TEN FEET IOURSE.
AND THEY GET A PRETTY TO THINK
YOU JUST PLAY, BETTER THINGS
HAPPEN.
HE JUST COMES IN WIT ON
I.R. -- GO.
TROUBA.
PANARIN.
THE SHOT DEFLECTION WIDE!
DOWN I I BENCH. HIS
MOTION WAS, UNLESS HE WAS SAYING
THAT THE GOALTENDER WAS PUSHE